[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 10 janvier et
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition
d'information locale sur tv 78 les
titres de ce set 8 journal le début
aujourd'hui des soldes d'hiver
l'opération chez des commerçants va
durer six semaines jusqu'au 20 février
ce matin les centres commerciaux de
saint quentin en yvelines ont accueilli
leurs premiers clients
reportage à suivre c'est l'une des
sorties à littéraire de ce début d'année
la communauté vient de paraître chez
albin michel
une plongée au coeur de trappes cette
ville où rien ne se passe comme ailleurs
selon ses auteurs ariane chemin et
raphaëlle bacqué lé 2 grand reporter au
journal le monde sur nos invités enfin
c'est une opération au profit dessus du
secours populaire qui débute aujourd'hui
petit pot pour grand sourire le principe
un don de produits pour bébé contre une
séance photos chez un photographe de
photographes des yvelines d'ailleurs
participent à l'action l'un est basé à
elancourt frédéric grah sera sur ce
plateau
beaucoup ont noté cette date dans leur
agenda les soldes d'hiver vient viennent
de débuter à dans toute la france et
malgré une baisse de la fréquentation
des magasins près de quatre français sur
dix avaient prévu aujourd'hui d'aller
chasser les bonnes affaires
miquel et demi d'euros étalés dans les
centres commerciaux saint quentinois des
prix cassés un geste bien connu une
forte affluence au niveau des caisses
les soldes d'hiver ont officiellement
débuté ce mercredi 10 janvier dans cette
boutique de plaisir une dizaine de
clients n'ont pas hésité à se lever très
tôt pour trouver la perle rare
ah parce que tout simplement sa part
très vite et que jusqu'à moins 50 moins
75 ans les bonnes tailles sa part le
premier jour où le premier week-end sur
un coup de chance on peut trouver des
choses mais c'est plus compliqué c'est
mieux on va dire parce que
malheureusement des fois on attend la
première des mains qu'on a pu l'état
c'est bien de devenir le premier jour
cette année les boutiques ont décidé de
baisser les prix dès le jour j pour
concurrencer les plateformes internet
les clients peuvent acheter des produits
au tarif de la deuxième démarque dès la
première semaine
allez on en profite mais da moins 10%
supplémentaires des deux articles
achetés jusqu'à 14h faut en profiter
c'est maintenant on peut passer d'un
pull à 35 euros 99 un chemisier à 25
euros 99 1 les vraiment les prix de nos
jours ont plus augmenté qu'auparavant
donc du coup les seuls sont vraiment
plus intéressantes aujourd'hui affluence
des grands jours également dans les
centres commerciaux de montigny le
bretonneux dans ce magasin spécialisé
dans les collants l'affluence et 40%
plus élevé que sur un jour classiques
bas les gens attendez un peu que ça les
salles dans un malgré les ventes privées
qui avait avant là ça les arrange bien
aussi de voir certains n'ont pas hésité
à appliquer sur la pause déjeuner pour
faire chauffer la carte bleue
je suis parce que j'en avais besoin mais
du coup comme j'en ai vu à -50% moi je
les ai pris je n'aurais pas pris s'il
aurait été beau de cette cliente
repartira finalement avec 20 euros de
collants dans son panier en moyenne un
français devraient dépenser 200 euros
les soldes se termineront dans six
semaines le 20 février prochain invité
de ce journal est son grand reporter au
journal le monde ariane chemin et
raphaëlle bacqué bonsoir mesdames merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
publié chez albin michel ce livre la
communauté sortie le 4 janvier une
plongée attrape son histoire sa à la
suite de distin glorieux à ses
personnages qui s'y investissent encore
aujourd'hui mais aussi ses tabous avec
ce triste record de 67 personnes qui
sont parties en syrie à faire le djihad
on va y revenir au cours de cet
entretien trappe je vous cite c'est une
ville où rien ne se passe comme ailleurs
dans d'autres interviews d'ailleurs vous
parlait même de ville romanesque
pourquoi était-il intéressant de
consacrer une enquête
un livre à trappes parce que trappe
c'est une sorte de précipiter de
l'histoire de france c'est une partie
c'est une ville où tout se passe de
manière exponentielle romanesque et au
sens large c'est à dire que on pourrait
croire que c'est un roman mais ce n'est
pas un roman
et tout se passe de manière
rien par exemple les émeutes de 2005 et
un gardien qui meurt dans la cour du
lycée
ensuite en 2013 analyse ce sont des
premières émeutes contre des
commissariats
en france il ya une synagogue qui brûle
dans l'année 2000
il ya des stars inouï qui sont nés à
trappes et que connaît la france entière
donc ça nous a paru passionnant c'est
aussi une histoire d'image est plus
général de la banlieue ce livre la
communauté oui surtout la banlieue on va
vous vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir
elle est toujours abordé de façon très
passionnelle avec à chaque fois des
positions politiques ou morales très
forte et nous on voulait revenir quelque
chose de beaucoup plus journalistique
vraiment une enquête détaillée nuance et
sans parti pris et qui permet de
raconter effectivement un bout de
l'histoire de france et un bout de
l'histoire des banlieues des années 60 à
aujourd'hui au d'accord avec à la fois
les la flux d'immigration et la façon
dont effectivement c'est la physionomie
seville a changé oui parce que dans cet
ouvrage vous à bali aussi plusieurs
années d'histoire vous l'avez dit vous
partez des années 60-70 à la base trappe
et est une ville de cheminots dix mille
habitants dans les années 60 70
exactement et elle va exploser quand les
recruteurs des industries automobiles
vont aller au maroc en algérie chercher
des travailleurs qui vont arriver
évidemment dans plusieurs villes de
france dont trappe comme les parents des
piles de blues comme les parents d'omar
sy comme les parents de
de la fouine donc qui sont appelés les
héros de notre livre avec d'autres
personnalités des professeurs des
associatifs qu'on voit tous les jours
sous s'entremêlent on l'a compris sur le
titre la communauté cela renvoie on a
l'impression que c'est une famille tout
le monde se connaît attrape c'est
l'impression que vous avez eue en menant
sa tante parce que 4 ap n'est pas une
ville chic grande elle fait trente-deux
mille habitants et ce qui nous a frappés
au début c'est que tout le monde a été
soit à l'école avec jamel soit dans le
même square que anelka soit en colonie
de vacances avec le parti communiste
avec intel la fouine au conservatoire
avec tel autre est au fond c'est vrai
que ça fait un peu comme une famille
alors la famille c'est à la fois
formidable et parfois ça peut être un
peu étouffant ça envoie aussi où l idée
de communauté à quelque chose peut-être
qu'ils renferment et aussi sur elle même
on peut avoir aussi cette notion là
c'est ceci le sentiment que vous que
vous avez eue
oui on voit bien que les deux versants
la communauté c'est un cocon où on peut
se retrouver est vraiment rap répond à
ça il ya des liens de solidarité de
familiarité affectif aussi très fort et
on a d'ailleurs été extrêmement bien
reçue à chaque fois et puis il ya une
forme parfois de d'oppression un qui
peut exister comme dans ces familles
comme dans ces clans très soudée et
parfois c'est difficile au fond de
réussir les pressions venant en partant
une forme de pression et finalement
une forme de effectivement de pression
du groupe
alors si on revient aussi sur strap
comme voilà comme communauté comme
famille on a aussi le sentiment c'est
une mosaïque de cultures
jamel debbouze le dit d'ailleurs très
bien dans un de ses sketchs il dit que a
finalement attrape c'est la ville où
tout le monde ce melting pour le pôle
sit & go dédié un melting-pot ça veut
dire que tous les potes ce melting
effectivement ça nous a beaucoup plu
mais déjà son jamel debbouze c'est le
poète de trappes avec la fouine
d'ailleurs il raconte merveilleusement
cette ville parce qu'en fait il a fait
de sa vie attrapé de son enfance au fond
le vivier dans lequel il va puiser tout
c'est râpé puis on a appelé sur la
communauté aussi parce que d'abord ça a
été que l'une était communiste des très
longtemps on dit ville rouge mais
c'était en fait une ville bleue parce
que tout le monde était cheminot
habillés en bleu et puis il ya le square
emblématique la violence dans cette voie
et les scores de la commune qui est
quand même le plus fameux des trappes
donc vous balayer donc on l'a dit
plusieurs années d'histoire vous partez
les années 60-70 a finalement
aujourd'hui donc au début c'était un
bastion de recrutement pour pour les
entreprises automobiles et vous arrivez
à ce triste constat aujourd'hui c'est un
bastion de recrutement pour
jihad pour ses voiles à ces personnes
qui sont envoyées en syrie 67 personnes
vous avez notamment compté ces personnes
comment on arrive à passer finalement de
wuala de ce bastion communiste à ce
bastion djihadistes finalement en fait
c'est un enchevêtrement de destin de
cause aussi et c'est ça pour vous les
raconter de façon plus détaillée
parce que pour éviter de tomber dans la
caricature justement il y as milk aux
qui se sont mêlés est aussi cet
enfermement justement ce huis clos qui
fait que effectivement on peut partir au
djihad à une bande de copains des
voisins du même square et ça aussi ça
nous paraissait intéressant à raconter
vous allez sortir un tabou sur cette
question quand vous avez mené l'enquêté
oui bien sûr qu'il ya un tabou parce que
d'abord on a mis un an pour récupérer ce
chiffre il y avait des chiffres très
farfelues qui circulait soit sous-évalué
soit surévaluée c'est difficile parce
que parce que c'est très compréhensible
pour les familles c'est dur un départ à
l'enfant qui part faire le diable n'a
pas forcément envie de se confier
d'aller en parler donc c'est très
compliqué mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est vrai pendant d'abord le départ au
dièse ils sont terminées il ya la grande
vague de départs c'est entre 2013 et
maintenant c'est fini et c'est un tabou
dans les familles à la mairie un peu
partout c'est une peine
évidemment pour des familles et puis
c'est un drame et puis et puis
effectivement c'est une sorte de tabou
français est un tabou de trappes
autre citation je voulais mettre en
exergue dans ce livre vous dites il
restait sept accepter ses codes ses
interdits pour briller il faut tant
partir voyez l'impression c'est qu'il
est difficile en partie aussi bien alors
pour lé destin glorieux jamel debbouze
omar sy que pour ces c on va dire cesser
ces enfants perdus qui vont partir faire
le jihad dont à option pour exister il
faut partir de trappes en tout cas pour
rompre rompre avec la ville une certaine
tension parce que beaucoup de gens qui
réussissent à trappes qui travaillent
dans les commerces dans les entreprises
mais quand on veut émerger quand on veut
se distinguer effectivement on l'a bien
vu pour les artistes
le retour est difficile les relations de
jamel debbouze ou d'omar sy sont parfois
compliquées avec la large énormément
lors de son premier spectacle en les ya
pas d accueil mitigé c'est évidemment un
très grand décalage quand vous devenez
une espèce de célébrités internationales
et hollywoodiennes comme omar sy c'est
vrai que ça ça paraît difficile de
garder un lien avec sa ville sa
communauté d'origine
si on revient sur la démarche nous reste
deux minutes dans cet entretien combien
de temps vous avez passé à trappes pour
très régulièrement pendant un an depuis
novembre 2016 et très facilement parce
que on travaille à paris enfin trappe
c'est tout près de paris et c'est vrai
que on a quand même été très
chaleureusement accueilli ça nous a ça
nous a fait plaisir et c'était aussi un
moyen d'évacuer les c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'il ya des caricatures et donc on
voulait pas tomber là dedans et c'est
vrai que l'accueil n'était pas celui que
qu'on raconte parfois au contraire les
gens on les a vus parfois quatre chaque
fois on a pris un temps fou et surtout
ce qui nous intéressait c'est qu'on a vu
aussi des personnes très âgées qui nous
ont raconté leur arrivée en france
comment ils avaient été recrutés au
maroc à oujda par exemple comment les
tamponnais sur le bras pour venir
travailler et qu'il n'avait pas
forcément raconter ça à leurs enfants et
leurs petits enfants c'est toujours
pareil d'ailleurs en france on a du mal
à raconter les souvenirs à sa famille
mais peut-être pas étranger c'est plus
facile
c'est des dizaines et des dizaines de
témoignages récoltés au final combien tu
as oui vraiment on a vu beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dès des genres très
différents si je puis dire effectivement
à la fois les professeurs ddd
associative des commerçants est vraiment
c'était très intéressant de se faire
raconter tout cas un pan de l'histoire
de france qui reste assez méconnue au
fond un à la fois l'histoire des
banlieues l'histoire de l'immigration et
et si cela qu'on a voulu vraiment
restituer la question très rapide on
vous avait déjà eu des retours depuis la
sortie du livre le 4 janvier des retours
de trappistes sur wii
très gentils en général oui vraiment ça
nous a fait plaisir et on précise que
vous serez donc en dédicace au pavé dans
la mare la librairie d'elancourt
ça sera le le 2 février merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous a rien de chemin
raphaëlle bacqué je rappelle que vous
publié chez albin michel ce livre est la
communauté donc qui est disponible vous
pouvez vous rendre notamment sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup c'est une cérémonie
traditionnelle en ce début d'année
guyancourt présenté ses voeux hier à ses
habitants au pavillon waldeck rousseau
est la soirée a débuté par quelques
prestations artistiques et s'est
poursuivie par la remise de médailles à
des médailles de la ville
temps forts le discours du maire
marie-christine le tarnais qui a fait un
tour d'horizon des projets en 2018 suite
des travaux des mailles des sceaux
l'arrivée de nouveaux logements sur la
commune
cette année guyancourt attend surtout
avec impatience la ryder cup 2018 elle
est programmée fin septembre au golf
national situé sur le territoire de la
ville un travail sur la sécurité et
l'accueil du public va se poursuivre
écouter on a travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années pour que tout se passe
bien avec la fédération française de
golf avec le département et avec 50 et
en yvelines
et on attend maintenant avec beaucoup
plaisir toutes les personnes qui vont
arriver sur guyancourt en septembre la
c70 huit personnes sur sur par jour
pendant la ryder cup énormément de
personnalités aussi qu'ils vont être
présente
et c'est un événement très très fort
coup dur en ce début d'année pour
yveline information jeunesse la
structure départementale dont le siège
est situé à montigny le bretonneux
elle ne sera désormais plus centre
d'information europe direct c'est une
mission de l'union européenne qui
l'union européenne n'a pas souhaité
renouveler cette année les explications
avec ce sujet d'aurélie rose il est
encore présent à l'entrée pourtant ce
label n'a pas été renouvelé depuis dix
ans europe direct yvelines avait pour
objectif d'informer les habitants du
département sur le fonctionnement et les
dispositifs de l'union européenne le
président de la structure qui gère une
trentaine de points et bureau
information jeunesse a son explication
la raison officielle c'est un dossier
très bon mais que nous touchions trop
spécifique - public de jeunes et sur la
belle ne consentent pas que les jeunes
je crois que c'est plutôt une question
économique de leur part c'est qu'ils
avaient deux structures dans le
département qui portait ce label une
saint germain en laye la maison qu'il
ait manifesté une rationalisation de ne
retenir qu'une seule structure dans le
département il vit une information
jeunesse continuera à informer sur
l'europe grâce à son autre label euros
desk qui s'adresse aux jeunes et qui est
centré sur les questions de mobilité
pour 2018 le manque à gagner de 25 mille
euros sur les trois cent mille euros de
budget annuel malgré tout la structure
est confiante
c'est beaucoup
d'autant plus que le rêve des
subventions globalement est quand même
sur une pente descendante assez forte
ça nous oblige aussi à nous recentrer
sur nos missions à nous organiser aussi
bien repenser les missions donc c'est
consolidera ya pas d'inquiétude
là-dessus on va continuer à faire des
missions mais voilà ça nous oblige à
être plus sélectifs dans nos actions
yveline information jeunesse souhaite
notamment encore plus développé cette
année les interventions en milieu
scolaire ou encore les opérations comme
le service civique dating en octobre
dernier qui a permis à 50 jeunes de
signer un contrat petit pot pour grand
sourire scellement cette opération
solidaire au profit du secours populaire
quatre photographes l'amène en france
dont deux dans les yvelines marie louise
le goff à conflans sainte honorine
pardon et à elancourt frédéric grah
bonsoir qu'elles ont invité depuis
plusieurs années vous est donc basé à
elancourt dans le département
le principe de cette opération le
rappelle c'est un don de produits bébé
contre une séance photo c'est ça c'est
ça
en fait les personnes qui vont
s'inscrire chez chaque photographe ne
payera pas la séance photo et doit mener
en fonction des besoins du secours
populaire des dons pour les enfants
essentiellement mots des couches des
petits pots des produits d'hygiène et
ensuite c'est l'eau c'est nous qui les
récupérons et on les reverra la fin de
l'opération dans leur intégralité au
secours populaire
moi c'est le secours populaire de et
langues et langoureux l'antenne est donc
exactement et après mais mes amis
photographes dans leur antenne dans
chaque ville pour les trois autres
voilà très bien c'est une séance pour
enfants j'ai oublié de le préciser des
séances photos pour enfants voilà
exactement ça commence à 9 mois jusqu'à
17 ans pourquoi les enfants parce qu en
fait basse et en fait on a décidé de
faire avec les enfants parce que c'est
notre coeur de métier
d'accord et aussi parce que en fait
c'est un petit peu les enfants qui sont
favorisés qui aide ce qui lui semble un
petit peu moins on l'a dit derrière
cette opération il ya vous trois autres
de vos confrères photographe
comment ça commence à démarrer cette
opération s'est depuis 2011 vous menez
genre d'opération comment comment ça
s'est décidé commence à démarrer
pourquoi vous investir finalement dans
ce projet en fait cette question en fait
rejoindre un petit peu ce que je viens
de dire c'est à dire qu'à la base notre
coeur de métier c'est la famille et les
enfants à tous que ce soit marjorie que
soir nous que ce soit marie louise ou
moi-même et du coup ça nous a paru
normal de s'orienter vers vers ce public
là très bien plutôt qu'un autre
et puisqu'on a pu voir aussi les années
antérieures c'est que il ya beaucoup de
parents qui expliquent à leurs propres
enfants que peut-être eux ils ont un peu
plus de chance que d'autres et je trouve
que justement au niveau de la solidarité
il ya aussi le discours des familles
avec les enfants et cetera en expliquant
pourquoi il vaut mieux photographe et
pourquoi ils achètent c'est lula donc je
trouve que c'est bien on rappelle
comment ça se passe concrètement vous en
avez dit deux mots avant vous apporte à
vous les produits et ensuite il ya là il
ya la séance photo c'est vous qui allait
reverser ensuite ces voix-là audio
secours populaire exactement c'est à
dire dans un premier temps les jeunes
doivent nous contacter pour prendre
rendez vous ils ont jusqu'au 31 janvier
- actuellement j'ai déjà 22 familles qui
m'ont contacté
ouais 3 sur les 22 qui vont carrément de
10 c sur un participent ces gens là vont
en fonction de ce qu'ils souhaitent
amener des lots par rapport comme je
vous ai dit des couches et cetera
on va l'y stockées chez nous et à la fin
des opérations ont fait une petite un
petit cocktail et il ya les gens de du
secours populaire de l'antenne elancourt
qui seront présentes qui viendront
récupérer tout ça et pour vous contacter
la petite internet via votre site
internet qui va s'afficher d'ici un
instant il s'agira au cours de cet
entretien
si on vient pour vous présenter un petit
peu présentait aussi le style frédérick
gravel et 10 un corps de métiers tournés
vers les familles tourner vers tournée
vers les enfants c'est ça exactement
donc moi je suis ce qu'on appelle un
pour un photographe portraitiste très
triste
et donc je fais énormément de familles
tout ce qui touche la grossesse le
nouveau nés les enfants les êtres
humains en fait oui voilà et et donc du
coup on a essayé de joindre nos qualités
à la solidarité
vous avez d'ailleurs été auréolé de
quelques prix c'est ça notamment à un
prix portraitiste de france excellence
2013 c'est ça oui ça remonte un petit
peu ça remonte un type jamais eu des
plus récents ouais effectivement j'ai eu
la chance en 2013 d'avoir ce prix là
d'accord
j'ai eu un 2014 la deuxième le deuxième
titre en europe policière européenne
photographer seront travail sur la
grossesse le nouveau-né d'accord l'autre
jour quand je suis passé dans une autre
émission chez vous j'avais dit que le
prochain challenge c'était le meilleur
ouvrier de france
donc je me suis inscrit et nous avons
les les comme on appelle ça les
règlements excité rails
on commença à pencher là dessus on
suivra cette actualité dans l'est dans
les prochaines éditions du journal merci
frédéric grah d'avoir été avec nous
photographe elancourt je rappelle vous
participé à l'opération petits pots pour
grand sourire à la démarrer aujourd'hui
et corrigez moi c'est jusqu'au 31
janvier c'est ça oui qu'on peut
s'inscrire jusqu'au 31 janvier et dès à
présent demander les infos sans souci et
on peut vous retrouvez également sur
votre site internet qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran du sport et du cyclisme à
présent le parcours officiel du paris
nice 2018 a été dévoilée hier par les
organisateurs on vous en parlait déjà
dans 7 8 journal comme chaque année
depuis neuf ans
le peloton s'élancera le dimanche 4 mars
depuis à les yvelines chatou a été
choisi comme commune de départ les
détails de ce tracé avec notre
journaliste sportif michael et demi
d'euros après voilà si en 2017 c'est au
tour de chatou d'être ville départ du
paris nice le 4 mars prochain le peloton
s'élancera pour un départ fictif de
l'île des impressionnistes avant un
départ réel à fond que et cyclistes
passeront ensuite par villepreux et
villiers saint frédéric
avant de s'engouffrer dans la vallée de
chevreuse on va aller chercher à coups
de boules et les trous on va aller
chercher la coupe de châteaufort mais
côté stèle jacques anquetil donc ça
parle aussi ses démons ses deux sont des
endroits qui parle et un retour sur
saint quentin en yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département à la celle saint cloud le
tracé de cette première étape de 135 km
a été imaginé pour apporter du suspense
à la course comme paris nice se joue à
quelques secondes près les secondes qui
seront prises ou perdu dès le premier
dimanche dans les humains contre ans
sans aucun doute eu jours après sur la
promenade des anglais
le lendemain le peloton prendra le
départ de la deuxième étape depuis le
village d'orson ville une commune de
moins de 400 habitants située dans les
environs de
interne en yvelines moi je trouve ça
bien parce que le vélo c'est pas que le
tour de france des épreuves comme paris
nice ça permet aussi à des communes qui
n'ont peut-être pas toujours les moyens
d'accueillir le tour de france abat
d'avoir une épreuve cycliste de renault
avec des coureurs de renom et épi pas
faire plaisir à tout le monde aux
habitants aux gamins des écoles pas loin
en quoi c'est bien une nouvelle
accueillie avec enthousiasme par les
habitants de la commune qui pourront
croiser les stars du cyclisme français
comme arnaud démare aux varennes barguil
oui je suis contente je suis pas trop
s'y glisse moi mais mon conjoint je suis
donc on va sûrement aller voir les îles
est un coureur ça va peut-être dynamiser
un peu le village quoi parce que c'est
un petit peu calmé découvrir un peu aux
gens de village dans son ville
une fois le départ donné les 22 équipes
cyclistes rouleront pendant quatre
kilomètres avant de quitter le
département des yvelines pour l'eure et
loir ils reviendront en 2019 pour une
nouvelle édition
cyclisme toujours son record restera
pour longtemps dans les mémoires à 106
ans robert marchand arrêt de la
compétition
souvenez vous il ya un an ce papy pas
comme les autres établissent un
retentissant record du monde de l'heure
et des plus de 105 ans 22,5 147 km en 1h
sur la piste du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le centenaire
raccroche sur conseil de ses médecins
dernières performances
un titre de champion du monde amateur de
cyclisme sur piste culture du grand
théâtre russo montansier à versailles
alain françon met en scène un mois à la
campagne a dit vend à tour gct et nief
écrite en 1850 et immédiatement censuré
cette pièce avait reçu un succès à
triomphale en 1909
c'est une pièce au coeur de tourments
les amoureux on voit tout ça avec
mélanie poquet
[Musique]
une impression qui va devenir dévorante
un tourments amoureux
natalia petrovna isla f la maîtresse de
maison s'éprend d'un jeune étudiant un
mois la campagne est l'oeuvre la plus
célèbre d'yvon tourguéniev une création
censuré en 1850
c'est quand même très descriptif douanes
et à la société russe dans les années
tout bénef a d'ailleurs écrit un essai
qui s'appelle un homme de trous le
journal d'un homme de trop et c'est la
génération des jeunes gens quand ils
reviennent après avoir fait leurs études
à berlin
il compose pour y associer tous très
traditionaliste alain françon signe une
mise en scène subtile et délicate où
l'interprétation retenu des personnages
masculins contraste avec les mois
féminin c'est aussi une pièce qui
fonctionne beaucoup sur sur les émotions
mais qui effectivement jusqu'à jusqu'à
flaubert et tourgueniev je veux dire
c'est seulement l'élite qui pourraient
avoir des émotions les gens du peuple
était jamais concerné par sa part les
états d'âme et justement dans cette
pièce comme dans les romans tourgueniev
ou comme chez flaubert ou comme stendhal
tout à coup je vais dire tout le monde a
droit une création au casting
d'exception menée par anouk grinberg les
is life vous invite à passer quelques
jours en leur compagnie
ces images avant de refermer ce journal
un projet d'envergure d'ici 2020 le
château de versailles prévoit de
numériser seize mille plants remontant
jusqu'au xviie siècle les 2200 premiers
viennent d'être mises en ligne
gratuitement certains de ces plans sont
signés le veau ou encore mansart
campagne de restauration défi technique
se posent les archives nationales la bnf
et l'université cergy pontoise se sont
associés à ce projet est nommé verse
paiera voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal c'est à revoir comme d'habitude
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]